a painstaking complex investigation
extreme weather a massive crash site and
still a scene of horrific devastation
all conspiring against the search for
evidence these the first photographs
taken inside the police cordon only hint
at the scale of the operation it's why
the families of the victims continue to
endure an agonizingly long waits the
devastation was so great identifying and
recovering bodies is proving extremely
difficult so difficult that some of the
remains of the victims may never be
found I totally understand the
frustrations and we have 24 really
highly trained officers working with
those families to support them and to
ensure they're getting the most accurate
and up-to-date information that they
possibly can it's a really complicated
and long and methodical process to
identify the victims and to secure the
scene now we have again trained officers
specialists scenes of crime officers CSI
as people will be familiar with and we
have a lot of those staff at the scene
still gathering physical evidence there
is a very high probability given the
nature of the explosion and the size of
the crash site that not all the remains
will be recovered it that is absolutely
the case and that is one of the reasons
why we are so meticulous and so and so
thorough in our gathering of the
evidence because we want to help the
families understand as much as they can
what happened to their loved ones the
bodies are in different conditions and
as the coroner has said the actual
identification process albeit we have
lots of options open to us to help
identify whether that's through
fingerprints through DNA even through
people's teeth you know that is a very
long drawn-out process in some of these
cases the welfare of the families is the
priority but everyone who witnessed
those distressing scenes will be haunted
by what they saw
there was some sort of incidentally a 27
cars on fire
lots of injuries PC Chris story was one
of the first responders to get to the
site a hardened traffic policeman with
more than 20 years experience but
nothing could prepare him for what he
saw it was unlike anything I'd ever seen
ever it's this whole thing you see my
film
lots of damaged vehicles lots of debris
everywhere
yeah pretty horrendous it was really
really quiet
really quiet no birds no aircraft noise
no traffic I see the road was shot in
both directions yeah there was there
were lots of deceased a lot of them
obviously I want to talk about what I
saw regarding that I've never attended
anything on that sort of scale or
magnitude really and it it sort of takes
your breath away when you first get
there and you see this entire scene out
of you
you know I know it's my job um power of
that he's seeing some pretty awful
things but this was on a different scale
altogether I couldn't help but you know
think about the poor people who had been
involved and lost their lives and the
amount of them I've thought about it
every day I don't see how you couldn't
really in the fact that some of them
haven't even been reunited with their
loved ones here you know that's a hard
part of the job the investigating team
gonna be a you know hard a hard job in
itself air crash investigators have
removed the plane's fuselage it will be
a main focus of their search for
evidence so too will be the testimony of
pilot Andy Hill he's still in a critical
condition according to research by
Boeing people are responsible for 80% of
air crashes but that figure includes
sabotage mechanics and air traffic
control pilots themselves are
responsible for 50 percent of all air
accidents
this is the last time the Hawker hunter
took off from its Essex base to fly to
Shoreham
the footage of the 1950s military jet
performing the loop will be poured over
frame by frame by investigators
[Music]
we asked pilot instructor david lee
amount to examine the film to see what
they'll be looking for here he is
running in positioning himself to start
his manoeuvre and he's now supposed to
be at about 500 feet now 500 feet is
really quite important because this is a
difficult maneuver and and it's only a
small margin for error now if something
goes wrong with the aeroplane or if he
gets his maneuver slightly wrong you can
crash straight through that and we know
ultimately this is what happened and
here he starts to pull up and he also
starts to roll slightly right to change
the direction of the display and at this
point in some of the videos there have
been a couple of flashes that seem to
come from somewhere near the aeroplane
but I don't think that they came from
within the engine or anything else
nothing fell off the airplane we've seen
so much video from so many angles
nothing fell off and the engine sounds
right and the engines the engine note
doesn't there's no bang from the engine
no backfiring sound and the engine note
continues at the same level that it was
at before the other thing is if the
pilot reckoned that anything was
seriously wrong at this point all he'd
have to do is to is to roll his inverted
aircraft upright and exit his display to
be safe and go back and land however he
continues with the manoeuvre so if
g-forces greatest here g-force he's
pulling hard at that point to try and
get the aircraft to come to pitch round
so that he's got time to get out of it
but at this point
at this point he relaxes that pitching
rate and I think it was because he
pitched so hard in the early stages
he might have blacked out or partially
blacked out then he relaxed he got his
consciousness back looks out the window
realizes that he's in a predicament and
then he's pulling up furiously his way
of trying to save everybody that was on
the road is by seeing if he can get out
of it in time by pulling it up but he
pulls it through the stall even though
the aircraft's going quite far
it can't provide you enough lift for him
to get away eleven families are grieving
desperately waiting for answers they may
soon learn how their loved ones died but
they will also want to know why Ashish
Joshi Sky News sure